et puisque nous parlons du ministère de
la santé cette mise au point tout à
l'heure à propos de la sphère du
distilbène le ministère prend acte de l'
enquête dont nous parlions hier soir qui
tend à confirmer les dangers de ce
produit chez la femme enceinte mais qui
sembleraient fort heureusement ajoute le
communiqué indique que le phénomène n'a
pas la même ampleur ni la même gravité
que dans d'autres pays d'une manière
générale d'ailleurs les milieux médicaux
sont plutôt rassurants ce soir et jérôme
camille s'attache à répondre aux
questions que peuvent se poser les
femmes qui ont utilisé ce produit
depuis la publication du rapport du
docteur cabot yajima n'import partout en
france des femmes qui je crois concernés
interroge gynécologue ce rapport
concerne des mères à qui on a administré
ce médicament et plus encore leur
descendance des jeunes femmes qui ont
aujourd'hui entre 20 et 30 ans et qui
s'inquiète pour une éventuelle grossesse
au chanteur je suis venu vous voir parce
que j'ai lu dans la presse que le
disciple pouvait avoir des problèmes
pour une éventuelle grossesse et j'ai
appris que moment avait pris la 10 cl
bell lors de sa grossesse et j'aimerais
savoir ce qu'il faut que je fasse alors
vous allez être mariée depuis quelques
temps et j'ai remarqué depuis peu ri et
vous avez envie d'avoir un enfant
prochainement oui alors ce que tu me
conseilles c'est qu'on refasse une radio
de votre thé russe oui c'est pas un
examen très compliqué c'est un petit peu
désagréable et avec la radio on pourra
avoir une opinion sur les conséquences
éventuelles du distilbène chez vous de
deux choses l'une où votre adieu
parfaitement normal et vous aurez des
enfants sans problème comme monde où
elle n'est pas tout à fait normal et
quand vous serez enceinte on vous
considérera comme ayant une grossesse à
haut risque ce qui veut dire qu'on vous
surveillera de près que s'il le faut
vous mettra au repos et qu'on a comme ça
des chances de vous éviter d'avoir un
accouchement prématuré au pire vous
risquez par exemple de faire une fausse
couche comme ça a dû être le cas de
votre mère puisque avant de vous avoir
c'est parce qu'elle avait fait une
fausse couche que vous avez lu ce
traitement puisque à l'époque on pensait
maintenir les grossesses grâce à ce
médicament le médicament lui-même mais
ni dieu ni diable en fait le véhicule
destroy et dieu et diable car ça a été
le premier médicament qui a arrêté le
cours d'un cancer dans l'histoire de
l'humanité le cancer de la prostate en
1942 docteur raguine chicago il est le
prix nobel pour ça à juste titre arrête
les cancers de la prostate maintenant
quinze ans après cette histoire des
choses d'ailleurs des smiths pour
sauvegarder les grossesses la
conséquence ses troupes du vagin et
d'utérus c'est le diable maintenant
ensuite comme disait madame cabot la
pilule du lendemain on re autorise aux
états unis alors qu'il était interdit le
médicament comme pilule du lendemain qui
n'est d'ailleurs pas la meilleur feeling
le lendemain mais cela dit pour montrer
après le veau aux hormones c'est aussi
le diéthylstilbestrol mal utilisé c'est
le diable donc vous voyez ça dépend
comment prescrits ça dépend comment
c'est tout est question d'éducation
il faut faire des sciences fondamentales
il faut apprendre aux médecins à se
projeter dans l'avenir leur donner une
éducation de base et pas seulement des
recettes en faire des machines à
distribuer des produits
le diable c'est le risque de cancer inca
sur 10000 bien sûr c'est encore trop
mais à y regarder de plus près on s'est
sans doute montré beaucoup trop
alarmiste